what's up guys Greg Lee hi John Humphrey
first major the real eject ship boy to
come we're going to review continue our
retro movie review series on Stranger
Tides Pirates of the Caribbean
yeah just keep doing that this whole bit
of you doing the view coughing during my
intro arts the Caribbean Stranger Tides
guess what Johnny Depp's back you know
well does that give you know who else is
back not a lot of other people are below
sea Barbie Z is in the heezy okay this
would be the third time I'm watching
this movie oh boy third time I'm
watching it first two times I saw it I
did not watch it right after watching
pirates three took it and I think that's
what made me and I think part four is
generally perceived as the worst of them
all and I don't blame people for saying
that part for frustrating part for I'd
like I get one yeah Tom and watching it
back to back from worlds end to this I
gotta say I definitely enjoy a tit the
first few times Assad watching it this
time
Oh like I enjoyed this more than part
three because it's at least trying to
have fun I don't have it granted that
doesn't mean I don't notice all the
problem yeah I don't think I'll meet you
in a weird middle graze it was weird
watching these both for the first time
back-to-back like yeah I think it's just
way easier to enjoy the part three
definitely I feel like part four is a
lot more lean and a lot more enjoyable
however I think it's a lot more syllabus
oh I'm like it won't feel like as much
of a mess and as chaotic as lumpy as
three is it still has a soul I never
know so try and it's a necessary chapter
this feels like franchise and it has
been in habits make a part for with all
jackets on adventure was it perhaps
worthy of a whole Phil Garrett yeah it's
just all Jack all Jack now let's take
the thing that worked well in moderation
make it the spoke I mean from beginning
I remember the my biggest complaints
came from watching it in the first 30
minutes I would kept pointing out like
there's no there's really no specific
style to the way this film is captured
it has no real substance behind the
camera like Gore Verbinski had a very
signature touch to all three pirates
films they're all shot differently with
a lot of it's specific that the wordix
players play they have a visual BM birth
like everything is huge all the shots
look like paintings and he really took
the time to make sure that you were
really seeing and drinking in sets and
the costume yet everything it made the
world feel huge and feel real don't you
know the world here doesn't it feels
more what I said halfway through and
then I ended up finding out this was
sure after the movie was done I said
this feels like when you have a School
Book Fair and then you find a Pirates of
the Caribbean rock inspired by the movie
in doing the adventures of jagged
marathon dance it like hits all the way
through and that was a tremendous call
because apparently this is a place look
they've got a book called I think it's
based on a book on Stranger Tides that
is about finding the Fountain of Youth
okay and it feels exactly like that sort
of feels like I'm made for TV I'm rude
you can feels like a made-for-tv rude
Disney original film oh yeah I mean the
first for off the bat like just the look
of everything lit differently it's shot
differently like they don't take
advantage of much of a that says
everything is CGI Prag what do you
lately it's more than just different
it's lackluster
yes the colors are washed out and if a
training isn't inspired and like there
are times where especially as some of
those like boat scenes I'm like that's a
big floodlight you guys are on it sounds
yeah we're the post like the first three
felt very composed they felt like they
were storyboarded yeah here a lot of the
town like like you said it better like
there's something kind of cool too
making it feel more like your semi real
time with these guys more just like the
reality of your pirate world in the room
yeah yeah we could like the shot kind of
go on it really looks like okay where
are we filming today I'm gonna go get
coverage here let's get coverage here
yeah what let's do the shot close-up on
him call him master shot here like it is
how well there's no specific style to
the way any of it is done and Johnny
Depp had first beats a couple times I
thought he was just bored
he looks pretty bored of the first like
half hour this film yeah he does this
time around it just seems like he's just
showing up on set doing his the Oh Jack
Sparrow thing and then calling it a day
because the was the biggest issue with
this one was there's no emotional stakes
yeah all know emotional say there's no
real emotional motivation but there's
hardly stakes for anything because like
the laws of physics and the laws of
common senses don't apply anymore to
Jack Sparrow like Jack Sparrow doesn't
even look worried by any of the known I
should be thin no he's not but in terms
of just everyone in this film well yeah
the only people that gave actual
character motivation to was Penelope
Cruz and the black beard ian mcshane and
even this story could have been more in
gaming yeah like they had plot elements
I thought if they hone in on those
better it would have worked too like
Penelope Cruz and Jack Sparrow finding
out and our a happen in the film that Oh
Jack kind of loved her at one point like
why didn't you just kind of like
introduce that element a little stronger
and has that be of a more crucial
element so that way I could have felt oh
this is what do I Jack's on this mission
this is why Jack doing this way is so
involved here was kind of like a Jax's
part of another adventure and you just
didn't really sign up for her it's kind
of going mad like I know the third well
I know it starts off with you looking
for the Fountain of Youth but like I
said there's no real emotional
motivation for Jack involved in this and
if you're going to make him the primary
focus of the film the primary central
character of it where you get way more
Jack time in the film you gotta gotta
enhance that a little beauty I to
enhance it he was weird to make it a
story about Jack not looking for a boat
or crew finding out that somebody is
impersonating him and getting involved
yeah an odd set up for like a Jack
Sparrow tale
you know I feel like you could have gone
with something stronger that's the thing
about this whole movie in the script I
wear as part three felt like it was a
sick drive it was like probably draft
number 12 and they could have used a few
more drafts I felt like this was like
draft number two yeah and they could
have used a bunch more because nothing
there's hardly even any interesting
dialogue in this movie like half the
time talking about the plot you know the
movies never intense and the movies
never exciting but I got what I got the
third time around I was like I find this
much more enjoyable than part three
that's the only saving grace for me in
this film is the comparison game okay I
stand alone film I think that's why I
hated it both times in the year since I
saw part three so just watching it as
its own thing like that is terrible this
is lackluster there's a strong lack of
passion involved in the filmmaking here
yeah and and and but there's sequences I
like I like the whole mermaid stuff I do
I personally enjoyed that like the one
mermaid sequence or they all turned
scary and [ __ ] I liked that and I
laughed a lot more in this and the third
one is there's a lot more jokes to be
had that actually hit Blackbeard's cool
a pun introduction he kind of B becomes
lackluster as the film continues to go
on he's kind of the calypso of this
movie like oh you're building it up and
yeah okay yeah all right yeah um but you
know so the feels rather forgettable
honestly because there's no stakes
that's the thing there's no stakes
yeah there's no stakes there's no
there's no tents there's no suspense
yeah there's no one seems that engaged
by anything that's going on and it's a
great adventure for them like traveling
to the Fountain of Youth is a very
Pirates of the Caribbean thing to do and
yeah I it's weird as much of a mess as
the third movie is it less much more of
an impression on me because the fourth
one just becomes a blockbuster it just
becomes a Hollywood movie kind of like
one to me was like going from watch
Lord of the Rings - watching The Hobbit
where I'm like wait a minute all this
stuff you used to do with real stuff for
the most part like the first three even
though the third one's bloated the CG
more than the other - it still feels
like they animated what they had to and
in this movie feels like they animated
just most students and the Merman like
the mermaid sequence I thought that was
really cool but I found myself missing
Gore Verbinski that whole time going we
could have seen something even though
you know script would have been better
if Verbinski totally a total film from
beginning to end would have been a
million times more a tree-like Verbinski
did it Rob Marshall brought like no
flavors no flavors there's no style it's
captured in the simplest way you could
capture a pirates film yeah it captured
like a made-for-tv movie of fire by a
children's book I get it it's like if
pirates 3 is is bloated hokey with too
many kinds of sauce on it pirates 4 is
just 2 pieces of bread and like a slice
of lunch meat like it's a competent
sandwich but yeah it just doesn't I
don't know it's weird I think it's a
better assembled movie than the third
one and I don't know if I would want to
watch the third one again but I also
don't know if I would want to watch the
fourth one again because yeah the fourth
one doesn't on Sony well I mean even
when like they have the whole even when
they get to the Fountain of Youth and
all this stuff starts happening I just
feel like echo never there were elements
there that sound cool on paper that are
technically ofall you scary mermaids
even boo do stuff would have been cooler
if it more enhanced you know but they
felt like they really dialed it back I
felt like there was someone at the
studio that was saying you know the
third one got a little too dark a little
too mystical ellipses there's only have
like sporadic moments of it here because
we don't want to hone in on it too much
due to work let's just add up a few were
there a couple things I liked about this
I like this better than third on the
sets I thought it expanded the world
more it brought in some new characters
it went some new places we got to see
some different scenery and I actually
liked the thing between the mermaid girl
and the cleric yeah I thought that was a
cool character I wanted to see more of
him confused
those are the two characters in the
movie that looked truly engaged and why
they showed up to be sue my big carrot
is that they were in a pirates movie
yeah and and I for most what does a good
job Geoffrey Rush's a good job yeah yeah
always good even if his material is that
right you know and there's some there's
some good laugh out loud moments I think
to be had I really do think there was a
couple of moments where I really like
Jack made me laugh a good not all the
time I feel like most jokes fail but I
feel like there was a couple of few good
times I'm like I laughed pretty hard
there are more jokey jokes but yeah like
when the jokes are good they're still
good yeah yeah fun and there's still
Jack's mannerisms yeah but I don't know
I preferred over the third one but
that's really not saying much especially
if you see how I felt about the third
one I don't honestly I think I prefer
the third one just because it comes down
most people do it comes down to the soul
for me and like this movie just traded
in soul yeah this movie lacks soul but I
feel like it's still more enjoyable it's
the more we in a weird way it's still
it's still more fun for me to watch it
has a real pace it's more consistent and
it's not angsty and dour yeah alright
well yeah I would give it a half of a
half a Greggy
I'll give it a quarter of a John there
you go guys I think it's okay there you
go that's my good mine I think it's okay
to bag some words there it is kind of
trite sure let's go to the real rejects
check out John and John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager Blum house comm click that
notification to honor Elena watch
pirates 5 keep a look at